تتولى كذلك مهمه انقاذ البشر من تحت
الانقاض في الجن في الجانب السوري
تحديث سيد بشير لمعطى
المباني التي تهدمت
وقبل ان اتابع في السؤال انوهه الى الصور
التي نشاهدها اذا على الشاشه هذه الصور
تظهر
السيده التي نجت اذا من احد الابنيه التي
انهار جزء منها في اضنه انهار جزء منها في
اضنه اذا
واخرجوها اذا من هذا الجزء المهدم من
المبنى اذا في اضنه هذه الصور مباشره
تاتينا من هناك
وهذا يدفعني اذا لاكثر اسال عن الابنيه
المهدمه عدد او رقم مثل
حتى الان جرى احصائه بانها انهارت ما الذي
سيترتب عليه من اعداد ضحايا وبالتالي
الجهود
للوصول اليهم
نعم
يتوقع ان يزداد عدد الضحايا للاسف الشديد
في مناطق الزلزال وهي عشر محافظات تركيه
كبيره كما تعرفون ان الابراج السكنيه
الموجوده في هذه
المناطق تحتوي على
ادوار كثيره على الاقل خمسه سته ويمكن تصل
الى عشره و15
بطبيعه الحال عمليه الانقاذ ستاخذ وقتا
والايام الاولى في عمليه الانقاذ مهمه جدا